hello everyone and a warm welcome to the
president design world 2020 fireside
chat from dream to reality
i am yuhao and i am infam and we are
your mcs and moderators today
without further ado let's welcome
professor joseph lim associate professor
of department of architecture college of
design and engineering national
university of singapore to give a short
introduction about this event problem
please
um
good evening everybody and i think there
must be a reason why the department uh
asked me to post
this
evening because i think at some point
all the three speakers here have gone
through a studio at a time when i was a
junior lecturer
and i'm happy to see you guys again all
grown up and always everyone
uh good evening to head you see also
uh let me give a very short introduction
about our event tonight and our speakers
first off i'd like to thank the ura and
the tasks for putting this team together
the
blessings of department the event is
part of the president design award known
as the pda outreach
it is organized by pda in partnership
design singapore council
and the urban redevelopment authority
and supported by nus department
architecture and the architectural
society
adopting uh well we're here with a
hybrid format together and we have
students
who are from nus three i see some of
them very hard working coming straight
from the studio and npsh
and
we have students from sutd polytechnics
ite
sota lassal and nafa who are also
joining us because they have a visual
arts program and they usually come to us
in the first year uh all very sprightly
and have a good mix of the
pontang people
now the president design award is the
highest honor for designers
and designs
across all disciplines
it recognizes the achievements of an
extraordinary group of people
making a difference to the lives of
singaporeans
and the global community through
excellent design
now the pda is presented in two
categories
designer of the year
and design of the year
it is conferred by the president of the
republic of singapore
since its inauguration in 206
41 designers of the year
and 108
designs of the year have been awarded
in 2017 the pda was relaunched as a buy
anal award with a greater emphasis on
the impact of design
enabling
economic transformation
raising the quality of life advancing
singapore brand
culture and connecting communities
and making groundbreaking achievements
in the field of design now the main
objective of the event is to inspire
students
and share insights on what architecture
and architects are about
after graduating from architecture
schools now the 3d three of the pdas
will share
their experience and journey
from being an architecture student in
nus to becoming a successful and
award-winning architect
the q a session after the sharing
moderated by test members juha and
infunk
will allow participants to have a
conversation with the recipients
i will now introduce our speakers for
tonight all three speakers tonight are
recipients of the pda 2020 under
the design of the year category they
also alumni over nus department
architecture first mr allen k
graduated from the class of 2000
helen
is the principal partner of formworks
architects and is awarded for its design
of the cloister house
i also first met ellen when he was my
second year student in the second year
studio
in 1993 okay
architects
class of 203
he is the chief executive officer of dp
architects and the designer of good life
we met when he was a five year student
and his tutor alicia
who is now in uh
designer professor yeah
and uh lastly
architecture
class of 1996.
he is the founding partner and managing
director of
laud architects
and also the designer of sparkle talks
large preschool
at pogo hi tui
i'm a nominee
i want to thank all of you
for taking the time out of your busy
schedule to conduct sharing for us
tonight and
we look forward for a wonderful evening
thank you
thank you professor drossos
before we delve into the session proper
i would like to highlight a few house
rules to keep the session running as
smoothly as possible firstly please be
informed that the session will be
recorded
for participants that are physically
present
please ask the questions during the q a
session after the sharing
for webinar participants please post
your questions in the q and a module
we apologize in advance if you are not
able to answer all of your questions but
we will try our best to respond to as
many as possible
should you encompass any any technical
issues please reach out to our technical
team
through the zoom chat function
it is my pleasure to invite our first
leader of today on stage for his sharing
he is awarded the pda for his project
the cloister house let's welcome
architect ellen k a principal partner of
the former architect i am
so i take out my masteries and
in a very good distance away for the
audience i have to emphasize that for
the zoom audience
so hi
um
i'm adam from formworks
hi
um yes i'm alan graduated class of two
thousand million boy right yeah
a bit of a black llama you know go back
i was born 93 73 sorry 73
and you know as architect we'd like to
find some significance to our
existence so my birth co-insight you
know
with the opening of my favorite one of
my favorite architecture sydney opera
house
there was a pretty long time to complete
by the really good piece of architecture
in our opinion of that period
i belong to generation x and and and
that's important because it informed
the way
i look at things and my journey
afterwards gen x and then gen x you know
and one of the synonym things is that we
are
united with the same common fireplace in
our living room which is the teletubby
we are teletubby generation before
youtube was uh has taken over right
so the journey begin i'll begin
no animation okay it's supposed to be a
roller coaster thing that goes on but
you know am i okay
and at 1998 two years before i graduated
these four innocent naive
classmates began to set up the office
from works
you know where we are fresh-faced and
young and optimistic with life
and the reason for that was interesting
we have the opportunity to do that
because it coincide with my early
ending of seizure of you know at that
point there was a one-year internship
that's mandatory but because it
coincided with the asian financial
crisis and i was let go three months
earlier than was expected so three
months do what set up official
and it was the
entire generation was motivated and
inspired by this dot-com
period now we don't have that on social
media facebook and all right of course
bitcoin and metaverse is a norm but and
then it was dot com every friends of us
from computer science business arts
was setting up offices website by
company designing websites
and even our peers classmates amanda's
the graphically creative or more until
the computers are setting up companies
so okay let's tell firm since
since everyone is doing that this entry
point spirit was really the the the was
was quite kind of something
uh that the
cow you know uh was among you know in
our years
or we are the only one that went on to
sell our design firm not architecture
from because they're not allowed to do
that a design firm an interior design
firm at the point where we are still uh
you know working our thesis right and
one of the
great advantage of that was you can
design your own office space then why is
that important
because as a student
it to me there was opportunity create
your own
island
your own being
there's something that you can be in
control of
and unfortunately unfortunately that
still goes through with our life that
you know perhaps i could not be like
jeffrey bawwa to own doonan ganga
you know i could create my own luna gaga
lulan ganga in villa m in turokura in
one of the corner terrace
and with that
at that age it's fantastic right you can
host your friends you can meet new
people
and
of course another way of kind of live
and work and play within the same space
that you call a workspace
and then in 2008
we moved to the second office which is
incidentally this and next in shenton
way just opposite uh is also the first
singapore polytechnic of singapore and
the building i was told
there was used to be an architectural
workshop of the architectural faculty of
the polytechnic so some kind of
alignment i guess
or destination so again we took our
office we moved
and the reason we moved was a very
singapore story because this corner
terrace was ongoing
supposed to move
to somewhere more central more heat more
happening and yet
as far as we can retain
the idealism and the exploration we have
we've become the spaces and the way of
life
and we move again
because
you are in a ura as a way to make the
land and now it was transformed that
piece of land was transformed the bus i
think a temporary pass interchange
and we moved a new
place turf club road and again
interestingly it was first completed in
1973 so it must be some kind of
destination that i go there right
and we are there now grandstand office
club fantastic view you know
but you know previous things doesn't
last long in singapore unfortunately we
have a
final date 2-023
because we were told that it would be
taken back and re-developed a typical
singapore story
so maybe at the move maybe in us there's
some space
[Laughter]
maybe a new new new wing completed okay
the joker yes from 203 or actually event
earlier because i was uh presenting this
like you know
where we officially
able
to design and practice architecture was
203 so 203 to oh
you know you have receiver exam that is
the past and kind of qp it was 203 that
we practice and build our own houses so
since then
that's our journey we were our houses
hinges on this emphasis on building
relationship between manner with nature
i'm not talking about too much of it
just kind of showed a rail project in
that period from 2000 to 2010
the range of of of
and design that we were able to get
clients able to get the confidence of
plan
and to deliver it
and from 2010 to you know you saw
over there in decades to 2016 this was
for further elaboration of our work
so there's a quick green shot of
the range of mostly houses
houses are always fun and
and we constantly we receive like um
resumes uh students uh graduate
architects that want to join us because
of our houses
and we appear in numerous publications
which is part of the journey it passed
our encouragement to get kind of
verification their work is being
recognized by peers and and it helps to
with a certain extent we're getting new
works
and we have a troll
a trophy actually surely to do
to bring this these are number of child
like you know you you pass your psle or
a level you keep assets so we have a lot
of these to hire or give meaning you
know in some way superficial way of our
existence and what we have done over the
years and why is it on trolley so in
case of fire we can grow them up fast
enough
[Laughter]
right but there's a fair share of
disappointments also right that that
with all these things you you have
awards you have competitions you have
pictures you have projects that you have
spent hours days and weeks and months on
and then
they will not recognize you you lose and
and each time you project that is that
you have spent your your dedication and
passion and belief system in because
once you do that right no other scheme
matters
yours is the only solution to the book
because of time
this is human
and with that imagine the cow as much
passionately went in
you are equally disappointed with that
so i try not to be but this time
and to this day would that change
perhaps right
no it never change never goes away it's
always with me i win i lose some
heartbroken and that's part of life
and okay on the bright side
we managed to win two building of the
year award by si which is something big
deal because for houses to get that is
is uh we we see the the recognition and
we recognize
uh a bit of comfort from that you know
in doing that of course the really the
the the
the the awareness of all awards is
finally in 2020 right 20 years after i
practiced
20 years of producing so many houses our
first house
got recognized
but why why emphasize stop being being
it's because previously when he was
inaugurated we do make a submission
you submit he lose
you have to recover because success will
come recognition will come and all the
more sweeter because as you know houses
category is almost nearly impossible
because the change of format and
priority
and embassies with the president design
work which makes sense you know every
award has its own emphasis so we got
this recognized and we're really happy
and great that finally we we we have
tossed this half-life of river
and of course 2-0 and our significant
moment was in 2013 we won
open competition calling for the moss of
impongo
uh ao isha moss right this is a
competition entry and we won it and was
built in finally completed
one five our first public project
after the house very significant
milestone because we we were affirmed
that we wanted to do more but as any
guys that said that you know you start
from beginning right you don't learn
unless you're extremely fortunate
through some means of competition right
you start from there and for years of
doing houses right now that we are not
doing don't enjoy that but we yield
because there are there are
there are concepts or issues
that public building surface
that you can engage in that you can't
find in houses so the types the varying
types is that and finally with that and
more importantly we thought for a moment
that you this commission right things
will be easier with the public
procurement and you know it leads on to
more projects but
strangely it doesn't come and 2016 we
are hit quite badly because singapore
slowed down we always come in cycle
with the current project we were almost
oh no there's not enough work to go
around
with the practice
with the partners you know what to do
set right
and then 2017 lucky lucky break so you
see it's important to be lucky and once
that you have that you have to kind of
honor that recognize it and give thank
you to whoever gives you the luck
for me of course
you know father in heaven 2017 china
kim calling
so a quick glance of that i'm jumping
over a place right 98 you're five
percent doing mostly interior right so
204 your 10 grow to 10.
interestingly in 1998 we have our first
intern from nus joining us
that was a big kick because you know i'm
a student doing pieces first intern from
nus joining us i'm junior so in 204 we
are 10 doing architecture practicing
arcade actually a small practice and you
know you stabilize gradually into one
tree or 35 of architects and designers
and and then
2016 happens where i said it goes down
and 2 02 0 because of the new thing from
so that is significant
because from 35 to 200 any architects of
additional sales
within this
what does that mean
a lot of stress
a lot of transformation
right but that's needed because
opportunity arises the drugs demanded we
expanded naturally as well so we are
doing at that point hospitality
landscape branding marketing technology
experience design digital fabrication
research
it's kind of like uh
not very responsive you know
that then suddenly you you know you have
projects you you you're starting some
capital right suddenly
you know you you study at one point in
time with no
we have no restraint almost go all out
to realize the dream that you have held
for like the last past two decades
and that's dangerous when the bubble
burst
right
but
importantly four years we have good fun
these are the range that we turn out
that otherwise will not be imaginable in
singapore
really from residential public
institutions commercial hospitality
which is hotel
to small skill building
like sales gallery uh kindergartens
primary schools clubhouse
commercial retail blah blah blah right
houses you know
this don't seem to want house designer
in china
maybe the local could do it a lot better
i think
and we were doing our first resort which
is a hotel which is impossible again
because certain types you realize right
if you are not in the list you will
never ever get the job
with exception so life there's always
exception just
just the need to seek the opportunity
and don't give up because that is the
main trend there is always a dominant
predominant way of how things work
you should go with the flow as far as
possible
but still take a risk
otherwise
i'll remain doing what i do past 20
years right so the first break came when
we managed to design one block not two
uh the design side by side with our dear
friend sukiyan which is great honor he's
doing wardog hotel and doing build next
to him as high rise that is also a real
kick and and we are able to contribute
also in a sense of the tropical
uh sky high rise in a way because it was
shanya similar
to singapore a tropical belt but with
there's attack annually by typhoon and
that inspired the entire design that
shaped this this concept of resort which
again departs for what you know you see
in shania which is all kinds of form
from
balinese
japanese rules and all that they have
exhausted basically all typology of
results and then we will challenge on
that and we pick one climate like
architect
primary response and
and from there shape a team that
surrounds it
and the other interesting project was
also unfortunately not built it was a
master plan was to do a movie city well
how fun was that right
now all coming into my
city that's on concept on building a
movie town right so of course with the
three main puzzle we tried we thought
the all typology that is
that is evident in other you know
all the chinese things like you must
have your child you must say
you must say
right
and the food
use this element to organize the
plan so that really drives this this
this whole thing rather than you know
port ratios circulation
doesn't mean those things are not there
but what takes center stage becomes this
organizing morphological
uh formal approach
that give identity in a way to a spatial
experience to
the the the city right so this is the
kind of
some render to show that one km bridge
that we talk about the child is one km
literally thinking one point to connect
three puzzles together that ends with a
pokuda so the axis you know all you
learn you know the urban planning your
own choir do everything
comes into one that's where you get
really i'll guess because
a question that was asked what were you
taught in school
the greatest joy is that you are able to
apply
the critical thinking
the lesson learned to apply actively
consciously
in the design in a real market
the other part of course you know
zero one technology fest you see yes you
know they have vegas you know that but
in stranger they are doing ones
technology fairs not architectural class
technology something that's totally
aided about technology which is
something we are also infatuated with at
the moment in time so how do you
represent a technology first so the idea
of second nature came about that
technology enabled facility technology
is not about how powerful you are how
how many gimmicks you can do how many
how easy other interface you do it's
about how nature naturally it becomes
power nature a part of human human
nature
so that drives and inform the various
totem in this case
to the pavilions to the the the layout
to the the
speakers there is always the speaker's
uh kind of
podium to speak so the the the this
sci-fi
screen to see there is kind of like
at the moment registrating
every different users can't come
concurrent by the speaker speaks so that
this live feedback kind of situation
they are not graphics they are like how
likely that while the lectures go on so
i thought that's something very relevant
and technology definitely can achieve
that right
so giving to giving form to narrate
was kind of a task
on something that's so dry and you know
technology kind of driven right or trade
show driven so to speak
interesting one more little thing that
we did with china again was interesting
place for us because they were very
adventurous with a lot of things you
know that's empowered by technology so
one of these was that everybody alibaba
included you know was going to be raised
who can come up with their own manners
uh supermarket or minimap or 711. and
you can see some of these are triggering
down slowly in singapore at that point
it was quite new so we begin to
understand
madness is not just
you know
only man there are still human needs
for
the uh for the
person that experiences space that is
right for instance you pay something
they they they use facial recognition
you pay by waving how do you know things
are paid how do you know you know they
have some answers so we went in to
design even hand gestures
that we patent you know to do how say
that okay you know it was it was this
this motion that that certified that you
agree to put the bill
yeah i mean little things that
how that from architecture from from
system design to experience could be a
modular thing prefect construction was
to consider so that it could be as small
as that to like multiple modules of
growing in size when
deployed in different part of the cities
right
and all the fun stops when kobe starts
so next part of the journey we'll cover
what happens
so we covered the big great thing
becomes go back we have to come back
home to the little black dog
to singapore because all
stand still in china not so much of
kovit but really because of mr xi
um policy that really crams out if you
are aware of the news
basically all private developer
has no business or in deep in a way
because of financing you know that it's
interesting you certainly are aware of
that and
you have no business at all
unless you are working with which you
can't regret for not penetrating and
working with the government on public
sector projects
you're just too busy and consumed with a
given work
now
we we need to re-establish type but if
not there's always singapore to trust
go back
in a way yes we came back and the size
like 115
woman so again pendulum
phone each time that swings right
this disappointment
is sadness
is everything letting people go it's no
true letting one stuff go
is hard punching
so it's not a number game it's something
that you you have prepared to do
as as part of this journey or you become
the sergey says still one person i run
the show yes then you have only yourself
to answer so that happens again on five
and again while that happens we also
thank our our you know fortune and we
must give them
you know it's not so easy come back
means you got a job but at the moment we
managed to pinch three important jobs to
sufficiently sustain whatever we have
the team that we established so one of
it was the new maxwell house no no
complaint really prominent because ui
center is a dream job it was something
that i hope he will eventually launch i
think in this end of the year something
i look forward to that we managed to get
our first city condo
you know very hard because 20 years try
trying always lose the sugar
because
you know like hotel like pipes are
it makes sense societies what's your
experience
right you go into
it's reality of work you know so so it's
always that that
when we are finally successful
in getting there we really are preferred
because it is important
and our project that was important
although it doesn't turn out
as much as we wish he could have pushed
it was a joint project with another
lecturer agent line
uh club key rejuvenation so the next
round that we are supposed to improve a
few things that doesn't work out in the
first
event which is maybe you know in the
noon time this place is famous at night
right it's like wow at night but then
day time is possible so we are very
going into this so that climatically you
know place making and how to improve uh
the river permanent bizarre it is a
project that is is this marriage that we
were undertaking and the other project
was an office tower in next to paper
tree again something a client that's
very enlightened to allow us to push we
are very happy when we were later with
project that allowed us to
to push and cross boundaries that was
come and accepted norm as office hour
for instance
so i
think thousand
times okay
okay
because like
20 years
so we are doing that we update mistake
guys to be ultimately we just formulate
we you know from works right so we
believe the new new philosophy is the
gift form to the future future in all
uncertainty the needs of future from
from means of housing to the way retail
should be or the way we work you know
the way we travel i think it was kobe
does present that accelerated that
process
um to to see to have clients to believe
that there's a journey to that i think i
think it's like a good moment in time
giving form the future the matter verse
your generation right there's something
that i have to catch up what the hell is
fluffy idea at the first
right but when your friends become
bitcoin millionaires that become said
you thinking
yeah
so
going there how do you do that concept
right
we believe in this because to establish
a very consistent framework irregardless
of project as i mean this we believe in
clause oxymoron to be hyper to find
hybrid to have a plus buy our houses we
realized it's embedded all the while
there that's why our houses name always
have a car prefix lid anyway house ram
house courtyard house open house
rental house
which in a way becomes a preoccupation
and guiding principle to testing
typology you know types
archetypes you combine archetypes to
create a new type in the center in the
example of the house right
and we i kind of visualized or picked
the image that shop the architectural
firm in new york uh like the
claim they they it's kind of like this
at both an end you know both a ship and
a
in a wolf right
or in today's context right ms tech or
taxi babe the mythical
rhinocon right why so that in a way come
back for the future what's the future
about ai right
so do things that ai the human brain
must allude and perform in a way that
the ai cannot mature
so become the mythical
minor content they can't recognize it
thank you
this is architect improvising
the kind of preoccupation to
set the stage because i was asking
something i say can i don't do it behind
a rostrum
okay i'll just leave it here
okay
let's see
oh yes very good
so uh
uh evening everyone pleasure to be here
because uh the memo that we've got share
about your personal journey
and inspire
uh young architectural students future
future architects too so and
set a bit of context disclaimer
so this is quite personal don't
blackmail me with some of the photos
but
i would say context is very much based
on
my personal journey
uh and uh they need to start off
uh it's also contextualizing it with our
local landscape or scene in terms of the
architectural space that perhaps we are
a bit more familiar with so start off
always go to the white span
uh which part of the face is light this
is of course uh confucius
and we all know so i was like well
so quite clear this part of my life
about things and apparently i'm coming
to 50 midway so i'm supposed to
start to understand
so ie conclusion is probably can't
change my current profession
and then one of the other things i
thought aok how to approach this
and my favorite way uh also to some
extent approaching architecture or even
questions to do with space is always
yeah asking the question and these
aspects probably will touch on three
probably to me one is from self to this
idea of team and then how has it
enriched the my exposition in
architecture
yeah so this is
me
yeah and uh
i think it was
art competition so very much i would say
this image links to the first passion in
life
i'm very i was very fortunate at six
my parents gave me access
to acquire
this life skill
and the life skill is not just about
technique but the appreciation and of uh
of art itself the technique the cultural
kind of influences uh that i think very
much own
this or see this first kind of interest
in architecture
second uh something a little bit more
energetic uh basketball so okay maybe
this is a stereotypical kind of way to
save basketball playing i'm quite from
so it helps a bit in terms of
the air that i free from more probably
the kind of
fuel vision and uh started since i was
12 playing competitive basketball for
many years and i would say one of the
key part about how the passion
in
sports has also helped me is to learn
how to channel this energy
and part of
basketball itself is also the
appreciation of team
the notion of teamwork you know that as
good as you are
it's also the ability and capabilities
of your entire team the other thing
again this is us postulation over
thinking or rationalizing our own life
right is that the ability to read the
field of play because you always need to
understand where are you in relation to
not just your team members
but your competitors and opponent and
the cool part is you have one target
that is to get the ball in and to win
ultimately all right so i think these
are the parts that help and from setting
wise uh i saw
who with my
okay these are two other big brothers
so same kind of setting i think it
affects 80 percent of probably the team
members and audience here home or in
person so very much through a large part
of my life
in the public uh public housing
landscape i think it also hones my
particular
sense and sensibility to some extended
obsession and interest
about the impact of our build
environment to our daily lives maybe
later you can see in some of the
projects that i will share and of course
after my journey in uh school of
architecture nus brought alumni off i
actually forgot he was my year one uh
not five final year that was with andrew
rondelus where he was the structural
uh
the thing about yourself it was very
interesting sorry i just add story here
so every time joseph starts to speak
softer i think that's when you get crazy
always remember about yourself
so you know it brings back so such sweet
memories but he was
fantastic has always been highly
inspirational and this was uh i think uh
very eventful was 99
i
got the on and on traveling scholarship
at that point of time at the same time
i was also
again just speaking like an uncle during
my time
our exchange was for an entire year so
all the five students and every one
student you send to a school i got a
chance to
get my entire fourth year postgraduate
diploma to do it in uk
butler ucl i think it's very much
i'll say was a
phase that really challenged but changed
uh and really deeply enriched my
architectural journey
and uh with that
with the opportunity
i found a job in the fosters in uk
from 2000
to
2002 and worked on
a project wembley stadium
all right so
interestingly and also a parallel or
rather to what island so i started with
big things
so i'm actually quite comfortable when
the project is big and that appreciation
of the power of skill
and of course with that i come to
another practice with
big projects so because before i left uh
then our chairman is the chancellor now
i realized oh he's quite smart because i
was interning in vp before i flew to uk
and then they offered me a sponsorship i
thought you know what vp golden now
people start escalate okay on and that
still
pretty much my life after i returned and
started also my life with vp which i'm
also a property member of and during
that moment in life across this years i
think i also developed in these chapters
of life so now happily married to the
love of my life and then we have three
bundles of joy i think this is the part
where parenthood has also taught me
this whole idea of how
we be better people and this whole
notion of purpose
and talking about the idea of purpose
and better people then moving to the
professional side so
from the capacity of life to the
professional capacity i think these are
two
aspects that again further shape our
journey moving on in terms of the notion
of team and the
bigger part of of how he has also
enriched the architectural journey uh to
start my first encounter with sia then
my team leader was mr tylisian so some
of you will know so now currently with
ictd
so um
i would say motivate but actually i was
arrogant
a team member said
sia is gonna
have this
vietnamese i think it was 2005.
yeah first i think of singapore's first
vietnamese follow far by giving me a
chance to travel
and uh and then through that of course
uh i started also my own
chapter in life with the institute the
singapore institute of architect and
then with that further participation
then it was anchored with another
major kind of gathering and festival
probably most of you will know which is
the artifact so it was part of the team
and then of course with the larger team
we created various programs
through
a space of
fest and allow us to continue to discuss
and create different discourse about
what's our take in various phases of our
nation building
in terms of what are the impact of our
built environment and design in the
psyche of our society and community and
again from their aspects there's a whole
team of people that i learned from this
is our council member i think
my last term because now i'm the
immediate past president so
if you see the mass on roughly that's
the period
yeah and of course uh the cool part
about sia is also the extension to a
whole depository and this all giants
that we get associated with this was a
luncheon with our past president 2019
yeah and of course some of them you'll
find very familiar faces
right that uh we further acquire uh and
and get infected by that level of
commitment and passion for
our profession and of course back in bp
this notion of team is even more
significant for myself this
my partners directors
all
good looking 33 of them
and one good part i always like to
describe about the dp's team is that i
use the novel comics
as the analogy right that everyone has
their unique superpower but there's also
a part of their weakness but
collectively we are powerful because we
are able to complement
each other's skill set very well so and
this has also allowed the team to grow
again this idea of capacity beyond an
architectural firm to a
multi-disciplinary practice offers nine
other specialist design discipline
with 16 offices
yeah get it right
and over the years have continued to
shape uh
landscape not just around the world but
especially in singapore so this is the
bigger team really from the context no
mass you know that was and i always
share and recently i just shared the
nice thing is every year dp will try to
gather
the entire office together in one of the
buildings you recently completed
so
any of us my own immediate team members
and teammates that i'm very indebted
with and i know that i never achieve
what i'm sharing without their
participation and hard work and then
from from there
this is one of my favorite quotes about
my own sense
of what architecture is to me right this
and from simpler you may have heard
about this is the power of how our
environment is designed
and um
and look at it from how it can start to
influence
users the people and from there when you
positively
influence
the user and the people they will in
turn start to positively impact others
when i say the word in fact it always
sounds
in this
that i can oh yeah correct
thanks
all right so uh
of course uh
at this point
okay the whole architectural expedition
of course continues so favorite thing to
the link i love to draw
and most of the i'll say all the
projects there will always be a little
sketch that talks about it but one key
part also in terms of
learning from some of myself experience
and journey and of course in positive
influence and lessons from
team members is the idea that
consolidate my notion of architecture
also as extension of our value system so
very much the way our city the building
is designed reflects who we are all
right in our aspiration towards it
and this becomes again a vehicle that's
extremely powerful that we can
capitalize on
further propagate good values and do
good things and do good for our society
so one project from doodling the sketch
that started how it's transformed in
terms of form and most part is about the
space that we create and not just the
space in terms of containing the
function but the space to bring
communities
of of all kind of age groups background
and unite almost the power the power to
united nation so that was what's up
in 2016 that were involved in this set
design
during that time so kind of very
meaningful to connect from the sketch
all the way to how the event happens
during that week and uh there's also
foray into space of heritage user
earlier housing heritage project
that uh city lights source
working with our senior and what was
interesting about it was to look at it
from a spatial term
from there to reinterpret and the
clothes from that was seeing more from
the runescape because you can't touch
the facades
right
and then uh the whole space of giving of
course not as many houses as ellen but
the idea of this high rise high density
and i think this was one of the first
few sky terrace projects
uh that that was involved
and even the idea of
other
high-rise leaving the exploration into
translating that to details and
tectonics
but i would say and this is where
the focus starts to shift when i have
access and more opportunities to look at
how through our projects and daily works
it can start to influence
different segments of our community
because our company's hub is one key
project
not just about this idea of a
development
which has many different components so
it interrogates and it looks at the
concept of integration where you bring
12 agencies 30 women facilities
how do you kind of start organize
complexity of this nature
a stressful 100
but outcome i think something that we
are quite proud of because at least
today i think it's the building with the
highest football in community space
uh pre-probing
uh i think 17 million
per year uh even with the last two years
it's about 12 to 13 million still really
high
all right what's what is uh delightful
about it is the different spaces that
you're creating here's not just a huge
development but it's actually a whole
series of different micro environments
and the great part about
obh is also the opportunity to engage
different facets of our society
and one key role in terms of design
process is also challenging
our own
efforts as architect when
the group that you're designing for is
this whole big body of a community
all right and uh to reach out to all the
260 000
residents of tampines was one of the
objectives that were set up behind the
projects in various classes for
participatory design
and then of course the different
engagement outreach and but it also
starts this whole repertoire in the last
10 years
of our participation in this space
within the local landscape and the
different projects that
myself and my team
dp has worked on
and uh i would say science matters but
small is beautiful and very much
about this project new life outcome
and and this is where you understand the
capacity of architecture to
really challenge
and empower
communities so stay alone seniors coming
together so through the idea of food
and the way we look at programming
keeping it the right kind of environment
you can empower state of the seniors to
shift from their roles of objects of
charity
into active participating members of the
society that they put for one another
they come together and give them purpose
and this idea
so we did an update for them so
continuing to do so in fact uh tomorrow
i'm looking at two more of their centers
so it's a part of what we view as
architects beyond
what we are doing
day job there's also these other facets
of parts that we can continue to help
and reach
and uh from the young to the even
younger probably your age so that's a
hardware network so this is for you
charity group that we designed their
workspace for
move to a new space at dangerous avenue
so we had a chance so every time
existing we always try to add some play
equipment and functions
so looking at depth space to allow the
users to configure
looking at different ways to encourage
them to create their own setting take
ownership about the level of interaction
and hope to
and uh
sorry this is the mouse pattern
and i'm first extending that further a
bit more people recently this is with
the sia team
we're also part of the team that looks
at
reviewing the design guidelines for the
foreign workers
all right
from mobility i had a chance to look at
a bus stop again not just pure from
function but how is also a part of our
social landscape to look at plug-ins
create different types of bus stops
environment and one great part is it
adds to the conversations of emerging
part of how architecture is shaping
space because from the integrated hub we
see the rise of a few more
then
look at different ideas of new bus stops
design configurations
it drives the kind of sports and and
this whole idea of more than longer that
places
nature or that setting but something
that can
really uh add delight to the everyday
lives of residents
about the the challenge
doesn't stop there so because of the
audience i thought
some of the destinations like to collect
things so this whole thing about
wellness and of course this is
incredibly english
but again idea of the larger
difficulties and
further in terms of how as as architects
part of a place taker when we look at
the bigger environment or the treatments
that we are doing with and we are
somewhat caught in this perfect storm
right where faced with industrialization
whole notion of digitalization
decarbonization organization everything
is coming in
also
but uh with that complexity also comes a
lot of opportunities so within
our own space we're looking at defining
or developing new matrix so something we
started 2014 again working with
the un-17 sdgs the the new measures
trying to push towards this notion of
evidence and outcome based approach
in terms of brain sciences but of course
uh keeping in mind the humanity aspects
uh and to be part of the active group so
dp is one of the i would say
first initiated oscillatory
of the construction declared in a motion
in terms of taking action for the
climate and larger biodiversity
preservation
and very important
uh part of the advocacy
all right so instead of complaining
and talk about change be a part of that
change
and we have a chance
so
this and and and then from there
challenge status quo green plan 2013 is
actually the fourth iteration the first
one started in 1992
this is 2022
so i look forward to the fifth iteration
by many of the team members here and of
course last two slides
i thought very important again from this
entire journey uh is humility
uncle louie one of the good life martin
residents
right because they said before the thing
was conceptualized he went up hey i'm
gonna do it i don't know anymore
yeah come come now let's let's help you
all right let's with all these sentences
his answer was no
right but after we rethink and reframe
the entire approach we went up to
uncovery and said hey
please come
and help us please sure i'll be down
there all right so the the power of
design
and of course last night
uh our unity
is idea of
a story of breakwood against something
lessons learned from nature tallest
trees in the world 100 over meters but
their root that is less than a fraction
maybe 1.5 meters how do they do so
right because naturally they tie all
their roots and networks together and
this is the power
all right of how collectively when we
are able to be part of the champions of
change we can really move
so with that thank you so much
thank you chipon
our last speaker today is architecture
founding partner and managing director
of low archetypes he received the pda
for his design obstacles for large
preschool at congo
that
so i'll be
very brief
you know the wonderful project that
process that ellen and um
have shown but today i'll just emphasize
on one project and
bring you through my inner thoughts and
the design process while i was designing
this project and maybe it helps to
eliminate some of the questions that you
have you know because you have asked
some of these questions along the way
okay so um this project is really a
child care
we call it sparkle talks pap
you know some of y'all might have
been enrolled there when you were young
the interesting thing about this
project is that
okay so
a few years ago we were approached to uh
join the competition for this project
and
um the interesting thing about this
project is that they really want it very
fast and it is very huge because it is
the first uh child care that contains 1
000 kids inside at that time it was like
the first child care
that has this capacity and
it needed to be finished in 10 and a
half months of construction which is
very short time so
as to um the very first thing that went
through our mind was that how do you
even conceive of a child care that has
such a large capacity because
and also what does it mean to be a child
care i think that's interesting part
about being an architect because every
new typology every new building you do
you actually learn about the ways of
life you learn about how things are
operated you do an office building you
do a university you do a child care and
through interactions with with the
operators we actually learned more about
it
important to us was of course the
learning environment safety and comfort
but beyond that
there are things that only the early
childhood pedagogy experts like the the
teachers will teach you and we found out
that in an early childhood environment
um the children don't learn by
studying reading actually they learn by
sensory and tactile and movements
because they are so young early
childhood means uh zero meaning infant
to four years old so it is a very mobile
it's very play oriented environment so
that set us thinking you know they set
us thinking on this trajectory about uh
creating a school that is really half
classroom and health playground kind of
kind of environment so that was exciting
okay um site wise is a very typical site
we are all familiar with page tv
states big flat um kind of like a tabula
rasa kind of thing no no contours
whatsoever overlooked by http uh flat on
both sides so
so it also kind of told us that besides
the elevation the top view also it
should be very is also important
okay
then how do you create an environment
for 1000 kids the first
thing that came to our mind was traffic
safety imagine like every morning uh one
thousand cars come and they literally
you know it will be quite a general
mayhem going on the second thing was of
course child safety how do we create a
safe environment for them to enjoy
so
uh the very first thing we did was to
break it down to three parts um at the
moment there was no derivation of form
right there was this it's just just this
instinctive back uh
fought to to scale to descaling to break
it into three parts
300 plus
it is quite similar to some of the child
cares that we have done before so it's
able to um it is conceivable in a sense
and
the form really came about because
the site was
pretty squarish and we thought that the
safest way to do it was to create a sort
of a safe oasis in the middle so the
traffic could actually circulate around
the whole building and drop off the kids
at any point on the parameters we
created three entrances and
uh
anyone that passes through this ring
will be turned into a safe zone that is
totally
free so step by step um i think the nice
thing about architecture is it's
um
we always
are in an exploratory mode we we try not
to have any preconceived shapes or forms
um it is more rewarding if at the end of
the day you derive something that is
totally unexpected but yet fulfills all
the things that you try to set up you
know in that way architecture is one of
the uh
the there's this excitement about
discovering new new things not just for
the sake of it but new solutions new
forms to to address the problems at hand
okay so so this is one of the
uh
one of the ways that okay that the form
came about the second thing if you made
this is really three coffee days um
maybe four years five years ago
um but kids usually they do
get infected by handful mouth disease if
you if you know but what i mean those
with kids you know um so what happens
if any of the classrooms uh one of the
kids get infected the whole class
unfortunately your classmates all get
quarantined they still come to school
but they can't go to the playgrounds
they can't use any of the techniques
ideally they should not
the circulation should not cross that
means they do not share a staircase you
don't share a corridor with the rest of
it so that's where the
this circular form
come into use because there are always
alternative paths and entrances to allow
for the the quarantine kids okay so and
we have multiple entrances
third thing diameter and scale
um
at this point we were we realized that
the scale of the diameter was about 40
meters
have you ever gone into a 40 meters
diameter of space
i might say not that many in singapore
but if you are familiar with pentium in
rome the diameter is about 43 meters
okay so it is a large scale we were we
were very
um concerned that the kids would be
overwhelmed because they are very young
small kids after our period by the scale
of the space um that's where we came
from the idea of breaking it down into a
smaller
more
i would say
an intimate scale
into three portions in right in the
middle you situated the multi-purpose
pawn
okay so slowly step by step it came into
this and how does it look like it it
basically takes the function of the
y-shape bridge which our functions are
injected inside below and on top is
really a clear area so you may notice
that um
this this this uh preschool has a lot of
open play decks and again it is a
reaction of our offline memory i mean
previously i was
one of the old i mean i grew up in an
old kindergarten nursery and it was
really cramped in the boy that kind of
thing um there wasn't many play areas
and if you if it's time to play you
actually use the
the playground outside hd but in this
case for a thousand
kids play
preschool we are basically accommodating
10 or
10 of these child cares together so the
amount of play space is really is really
great and the kids could basically run
round and round and really enjoy the
space and what the preschool teachers
enjoy is the ability to plan
different
uh activities for the kids okay
so these are the visuals of the three
segments
with the different play areas
and
one of the things that we wanted to
create in uh incorporate in all our
projects was really
the idea of natural ventilation you know
being in a tropical climate
it is really important and also we
wanted to create a center that
actually allows it to be operated in
totally natural ventilation that means
unless there's haze going on um the
whole center can be air con in the
classrooms but otherwise
um the air really just flows through the
space
okay this is the central space of the
dining area
and sectional wise we have attempted to
create a very high volume
such that the air itself becomes a
insulator
right just right under the tap one
telephone
um the app becomes an insulator and the
wind literally just flows through the
whole building
and of course it's aided by
um hdrs fans and this is actually a
simulation of how air is being drawn
through the classroom's opening and
expect right to the top so this was a
simulation of course it was done before
the building was built but
in actual fact you could actually hear
it happening one side
this was another view
and
uh just now you may have
you know i mentioned the the historical
building pancho new rule
it was a very
distinct memory the first time i visited
rome in pantheon it was actually raining
and if you have actually gone there in
the rain it's such a magical sight
because
why would a designer design a perfectly
shaped dome and leave a 7.8 meters
taping hole right in the middle to let
the ring in but it was such a poetic
poetic sight and i suppose that has
really
uh somehow inside my memory all this
time so when it came when it came to the
time to create this um big shelter we
really we propose to the clients to to
let us open the home there and
situate the garden right underneath so
that
you know the idea is such that we wanted
to create an environment such that the
kids will not be cut off from the from
the outside if it rains
they can play in the rain
if there's a breeze they can really feel
it going through um so after some
persuasion and of course some
stimulation
of of the rainfall uh when i should
convince the client which was actually
quite fortunate
so
so in a way this is similar to uh
another project you know in the east of
singapore
except our rate vortex only works very
great
this this is a you know
image i mean nowadays i i don't know
whether the the teachers actually let
the kids play in the race but
again there was a memory from down you
know whenever whenever i ran i worked
home from primary school to my to my uh
house i used to step on every partner
and play so this is
um the interest yeah again designing a
child care
really let us become kids again
it draws out memories that are long
formatted and then you imagine what if
you are a kid what would you like to
imagine what would you like to
experience and these are the things that
we that we that i personally enjoy
because
it lets you create
things and
good things to let the kids of the
generation experience
okay the other okay so this is uh
basically the
party diagram i wouldn't go too
the other thing about
uh creating childhood is really the
movement you know that's how i mentioned
the pencil so the idea of having a
single ramp that links all the flaws
from first to second to the rooftop
playground is really important
the
entry lobby and some of the spaces
behind
playgrounds so
instead of having building a building
with classrooms right in the middle and
the playground to the external we wanted
to create a space where
classroom and playgrounds are all
interspersed so at any one point you
step outside your classroom there will
be something and in this case two still
slides were were actually located at the
place where
the parents come and pick up the kids or
whether the kids wait for the parents to
come so we thought that it'd be great
you know if they can enjoy themselves
while waiting for the kids to come so
it's very interesting because it
happened that some of the kids actually
don't want to follow their parents back
home because of this
and this is an area of
water play and
this one is quite interesting this is
actually a playground for the toddlers
and the infant oh okay one minute so um
what we wanted to create was a a place
where they experienced textures and they
experienced a balancing the mode of
balancing so
you know i mentioned that's how kids
look right so
again the idea of colors and textures
that's imbued at every um
place and at every entrance of the of
the classrooms um
not least of all it's a sense of
imagination um we thought that it would
be more interesting to to to label
classrooms by interesting animal shapes
composed of quadrants of circles rather
than by names so this six symbols we
created these symbols to
to locate them at every entrance
yeah just get through
this so um this is how how the center
looks like right now
i think uh being an arctic is really
interesting to see how your space gets
inhabited
in this case by the children's hard work
and
you know it's very lively it always
changes and it they really make
themselves it it really feels like a
home
um and
the the sunlight that comes through
right now it was this picture was taken
at 4 00 pm in the afternoon and it's
really through the oculus right in the
middle so in a sense it is like a
gigantic sun now and the the moon and
the lighting of this place really
changes
with the time
so finally the rooftop
and this is the view of right
um so during the opening ceremony of the
building
the kids were asked to draw their
impression of this child care and this
is what they came up with right says
just circles as if you said uh
right circles of different colors and
different textures
so
finally this is a view from
thank you
now it's the highlight of the evening i
would like to invite all sneakers on
stage for q a sessions
just to be moderated
we are
please raise your hand if you'd like to
ask
our speakers a question
if not we have some questions required
beforehand
was submitted
through our link
so we will direct this question to the
clause
how do you keep yourself motivated
through tough times and what motivated
you to keep pursuing a career in this
field have you ever considered stopping
through the hard times
okay is
that always happening you know there's
something in the beginning you know year
one right every single girl here one
time
as a student
so the biggest things forever since we
we had a
when you're young
your needs change your family you may
get older right
perhaps
right there's commitment
expectation but that stress
of survival goes there
project itself
eyes and move your project that's
perfect
you mess up with an enlightened client
that's a dream come true but that's not
always right there'll be hard times
there'll be obstacles that you
always have to
navigate that's always
easier life there's always a friend that
earns a lot more than you and a better
you know there's time that you know we
come to the point that you know okay you
have wrong reality you come back okay
your friends chatting up for ski trips
and then you look at your maybe the
revenue of the year
and that
is fine whenever you are single
you have to find meaning in what you do
in your career
yeah sure
okay i i thought again this question
about tough
or difficult times
and
perhaps look at the parallel the
dynamics of that you know when you know
that
half time that means there's also the
moment they are sweet
right and
perhaps
my own experience about architecture or
i still call this the
expedition
that i'm still learning from
or experiencing
is that i value the sweet part more than
the difficult part
i don't know whether this is the
masochistic aspect of architecture
but
i would say
relating back to ellen's last point
this is the part where i do think this
is
one of the most unique qualities of our
vocation the part that
gives us purpose in our work
and it's important if we are in this
space pursuing this form of
i would say even career i call it this
location and in this journey
this is the aspects that we need to
value
and
the other part that of course comes with
that is the motivational aspects that
you mentioned so when you see
uh
projects that you have completed
not just in terms of the manifestation
of your thoughts the ideas but the
delight from the user's perspective i
mean it can be a
in this space we talk about some
residential project great house the
family bring them closer together
serving their needs all the way to
community spaces or even that we give
the example avoid next center of our
stops
so this is the power of what we can do
all right and and i think that's the
aspects too that's important to remind
us and i always say
in life it's not just about making the
dollars
and this is going back to our own value
system
right and and when we are interested or
uh
in fact as when we start our journey in
architecture i think
there's a certain value
that already unites us
all right otherwise you won't you will
not be even in this space
right or if you are
i think probably you can be considered
yeah
so i thought and of course one of the
motivation
for me personally is also
the part about learning from different
people partners as soon mentioned when
you do the child care you learn that's
the humility part all right you learn a
what actually kid's perception is uh
this low because our world is this big
actually kids look at everything in
magnified skill and then that level of
sensitivity and when you design for the
seniors uh who are staying alone the
psyche is so different and then the way
they understand way of life is so
completely different from ours so that
that humility part is so precious and
key and of course from our own team
members yeah i say safe to say my two
dear friends here like me we have team
members that work closely with us and
then their kind of contribution their
hard work their energy
and then their commitment are also
things that drive us
uh to continue to be focused and and
cast this
half part as something temporary
that we can definitely
overcome for the
uh the greater part of this profession
you know personally i feel it's really
painful to
feelings
for create
because um you know
you really benefit from a whole wide
spectrum of people up there and this is
one of the things that keeps me going um
because there are tough times and then
we have plenty of clinics like
colleagues that have left us and became
bankers you know or you know
they have of course they have different
uh ways to measure
but i do find our career very soon
that's enough to keep
thank you for a very insightful answer
um
do anyone in the audience like to ask
the next question
let's see yeah
maybe one of the
speakers help to answer would you
recommend a student who just finished
year one modules to start doing an
internship with architectural practices
was just waiting for my friends to say
yeah
i mean why not yeah why not
i would say it's important to get a
sense of what practice is like
but the choice of the firm is also
important
about what are you seeking for in that
say that
that that space of order this period of
learning
uh but important lesson
for all students and for us also
uh lifelong learners right is to
continue to keep your mind open
all right understand
say that the nature of practice perhaps
the challenging part the tough part
right but the again the sweet portion
all right and then find your own compass
i think and then perhaps sometimes you
see bad examples of things then you
remind yourself that's what i should not
do
all right or i want to do something
different from this so but such exposure
and such kind of immersion i think it's
very important in fact
i can add also yeah i totally agree it's
absolutely important because
the world how the world the real world
can call it that architecture operates
outside it's very different from a
control environment as it should be you
know this cultural environment is for
you to experiment with ideas and all
that but how real projects work outside
many of our young interns come and they
were quite amazed how how fast things
move
and how they have to deal with very
real things like budget authorities you
know all that kind of technical things
which is not not a bad thing um but it
is very sudo
while you are in this uh academic
environment you go outside and reverse
yourself and then come back again you
have a better appreciation of how
how uh
really precious history years of
university life is because you know you
you really there's no limit to your
imagination to what you want to explore
all these things you will have to deal
with eventually when you're outside and
of course
quite a lot of the sharp technical
skills as well which is also useful for
you to express yourself better in your
in your academic look so i think that is
one of the
advantages
maybe something lighter because
you know one of my year one classmate
right found the love of his life
during the year one internship
you know it's just a lie right now
so you have the opportunity right why
not it's just like the first trip do you
go to the euro right
is
[Music]
audience
maybe anybody wants to ask one final
question
burning questions
to repeat this question what is the
biggest regret you had during your year
of pursuing your education
you know there's a lot of requests
directors photographers
was that
when i stepped in year one of
the year studio right
all the arrangement of models
and that carries through the fashion to
do this to this day
practice and make sure i still continue
making some of it for me
remember the same answer there are
things that you must hold here that you
have continued
what other requests yes requests not
hanging around more and more
spending too much way too much time just
in studios
then i i
do the extremity of
of of not also having some balance which
is important because if you have a setup
those are connections
so a bit of minor regression
maybe more personal i i don't know i
don't really have like
this kind of state of regrets i know you
you're the man sometimes you learn about
things that you may have done better but
whatever happens
it's also a part of the things that have
shaped you
for your current state so and and
there's really no point when to look
back and learn from the past is one very
important thing but to stay in that
state
uh to a certain extent that
to indulge yourself in that i'm not sure
i thought it's more important from there
is to
look forward
to see what you can do better
how you can improve things made from
the space of safe design
and processes
and i agree with and then it's very
important that's why i said uh
understand your own uh compass your own
value system
and then continue to pursue you manifest
in different ways and
i mean the cool part about today's
sharing and learning is like you know
there's things and i think quite
connected from school days like this is
the things that i'm obsessed about this
latest bit i'm doing is like you know
you'll come back
and then this will remind you so yeah
don't let don't leave
[Music]
because there was one of the
projects that my tutor
thought that i i i was able to achieve
more
but i didn't push hard enough
uh you know at the end of the crit she
left me a little note in my opinion
always say
don't be afraid to go beyond your
comfort zone
in the sense that you know sometimes
design is scary because
good designs comes out of a real
struggle and understands of the unknown
and if you if you manage to discover
something that is totally new to you i
think that's a truck but sometimes you
may fall flat on your face as well you
know but
uh for that project for whatever reason
i didn't push hard enough and that was
one opportunity missed
and to me design is a kind of a
self-discovery as well so for that that
moment i
kind of
missed that so i wouldn't call it regret
but it's a
important lesson and while you're in
this
safe environment
nothing can go very well right you
should really try and push it as high as
you can
thank you very much for the exciting
answers
uh we would like to thank uh once again
again
for sharing your experience with our
audience before we turn it back maybe we
would like to invite our hosts
thank you
uh
and if you'd like to find out more about
the works of the three speakers today
their works will move to different
locations until during this year
you may scan the qr code this will be qr
code up there that will let you know
about the dates and the locations that
the projects will be at
thank you once again to our speakers and
all of you for spending money
you